で今日は外れしてそうです皆さん子供の頃から宝物と買って持ってますでしょうか北
古賀実家じゃなくて静岡なんで貸さ何ものっぽいたかなものっていうのを
ないんですよまず出ないなんだろ向かせ
ない宝物ない俺の宝物まあ
俺の周りの魂月後輩
そして
画面の向こうの
心ん
君たちだっ
という大きなた彼のことがないんですけれどもどんどん中でもなんか昔10回ってなん
か色々自分の何かおもちゃとか探しの時にこんなのあったっていうのがあったとのこと
で静かに持ってきてたのを思い出しました
第二すぎてなんかゆっくのこのカーペットの上に入ってるんですけど
[音楽]
あったてえっ
頑張って待ってもとっています
これっ
えっあったーーーじゃあチーズ終わったと思って甘いこちらですこれ初めて出すから俺
強いんだよなぁ
出す出すよ初めてですよ
西こちらでございます
あああーー
先に説明させてください皆様バトエンスってますか俺が小中学校の時にめちゃくちゃ
流行ってたんですけどもバトルえんぴつっていうのが流行ってたんですよ僕なんてた
小山中学校で一番やってたのはドラゴンクエストドラクエの魔物のバトル鉛筆が
めっちゃ流行ってたんですけども六角形なぜの鉛筆画鉛筆が六角形でフルと六角形の
どれ
彼にこう止まるわけですかなかなかなくなっつって止まった面2面か例えば相手に60
ダメージとか
候補に降りあって攻撃しちゃうっていうのはんめ
じゃないってたんですよ今今もう全然ないんですけどめっちゃ集めでてば髪屋に買い
まくってテレソンと聞いの生き残りの1本なんですけども
バーッっちゃったか次が動画さ月でそんな彼の市これ日本なんですけどもこれすっごい
いいんですよ
はいこちらです新品霊数がさっき2回落としてしまいました
どうレナスターっていう魔物で
ございますこれねっ
胸の追っかけだか見づらい前に50列50代で結構でかいんだと思う
こういう感じで振って出たのでこう攻撃は全20ためちゃ弱いこういう感じな鳩エンド
やつがあったんですよねこれねぇねぇっつ湘南です何か普通のバターンって販売され
てるんですよ買えば手に入るパターンが多かったんですけどこれなんか終戦系が応募の
やつでだしか僕の記憶が正しければ
ネック世界に2000本500本だっけ
ちょっと持っとくか世界に500本しかないんですよでたまたま僕その鳩に買いまくっ
て集めてなんか応募したら当たってこの伝説なバッドや puppet master
を手に入れたというねこれ調べてもらえばわかると思うんですけども糞レアです売って
ないですパペットマスターそこで私は怒った今ばとへ流行ってるの
今の子供だって知ってますてがみんな知ってますバトエン a オレの中核だけだっ
たらどうしよう
ちょっと調べてみますがっとるエンプイオン人気なんかな
公式サイトもないんかなドラ系の公式バドへの公式サイトもない気がしてきたところで
公式サイトからないば取れ5 premiere ちょっと調べてみます踊れマスター
で焼いちゃう考えたらじゃあ俺のは俺の評価た好きな混ぜ高いんですよこれ
道でましたって言ったらいろいろ助けてことにヤバイ
いやーやばいバトエンっていうもの時代が流行ってないですよ
やばくねだってこれ世界に迫ってそもそも正解なのかあるかどんだけで持つ調べます
me
ただ全然情報ないこれのなにこれええ子絶対当てて気がすんだよねこれ
だめだぞー方が何にもねなんだこれ本当に会でもホンダようにもらったんだよなぜだか
可笑しくにバトエンがこんな入ってるわけないでしょ
ね応募して当たってあのもう世界に何方のしかないパターンが当たりましたおめでとう
ございます
てくるとこまで覚えてるんですけどもそれが何かあったかもうあの情報が見当たりませ
んでした
イェイ何にも損ないですあのドラゴンクエスト大好きな皆さんで僕と同世代の皆さん
あとスクエアエニックスの方この場から本当にわからぬただ本当にあのレアレア
っちゅうかプレミアっていることだけはわかるんですよ
これが何なのかをちょっとしてみたいのであの良かったらみなさんコメント欄で教えて
ください
もう1回言いましょうドラゴンクエストの堂宇マスターという鉛筆でございますた世界
で本当優勢の鉛筆ですではまさっき調べていたとき張ったひとつだけの情報がありまし
たメルカリでなんとこれと同じやつ
売られていますもソールドで買われてましたやっぱ買う人がいるみたいだけどもういい
腰売品が付いてて二つでお値段の方
なんと
[音楽]
900円
ええええええ
me
あっはぁ